good afternoon everybody
it's 5:30 so we're gonna start this
meeting will be broadcast on YouTube in
accordance with the first paragraph on
the front of your papers just a brief
reminder apologies for absence
declarations of interest by councillors
item three mca nineteen slash one to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the fourth of March page 1 page 2
page 3 page 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 are you
will happy that I sign these
to receive notifications or petitions in
accordance with a Council's petition
scheme none received questions by
councillors matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committee item 7 MCA 19/2
forthcoming decisions list and page 13
item 8 mca 19 / 3 the general fund yes I
just like to come clarification on which
is the most current decision less
because we've been given one dated 7th
of June now are we approving that or the
one dated 31st May thank Jenna so you're
not approving it you're just noting it
but but it will be the one with the most
recent dates what we tend to do is
publish the relevant one at the time the
agenda is published but it's a live
document that's constantly updated on on
the website so that was pretty angry
Sebastian so item 8 mca 19 / 3 the
general fund financial downturn for
2018-19
it's going to be introduced by council
of white tape thank you madam chairman
I'm pleased to introduce report MC 19 /
3 on the general fund financial out turn
which starts on page 25 of our covenant
papers madam chairman and members have
been blessed with an abundance of extra
mainly one-off income in 2018-19 the
overall picture is that we are three
point four six two million ahead of the
balanced budget we set ourselves that
starts the year now that's a big number
but just four items make up over
three-quarters of that variance and
they're set out in paragraph five point
two and they are business rates of 1.9 3
4 million the Silph 5% admin slice at
340 1000 a Housing Benefit subsidy from
the government of two hundred four
thousand and election reimbursements and
many previously satisfied for elections
but no longer needed which total hundred
four to two thousand
now clearly the extra business rates
receipts by far and away the largest
item and since the introduction of the
retention of business rates we've always
cautioned in our budget papers that the
forecasting of our business rate income
with fluctuating business base alongside
a tardy appeal system which come back to
a green banks for several years these
would always be subject to a high level
forecasting uncertainty compared to the
old revenue support grant system we used
to work under among the various is this
year is a section 31 grant at 7 or
16,000 which has doubled as a result as
being in the business rates retention
pilot now despite the inherit inherit
uncertainties we see establishing better
systems to improve business rate
forecasting as a key objective for the
finance team in 2019 20 so we're
recommending that all this 1.9 3 4
million additional business rates
received are transferred to the business
rates equalization reserve the balance
of on that will then be just below 3
million but because allocated deficits
work two years in arrears we actually
anticipate that account falling to just
above 1 million by the 31st of March
2021
now a tabulation of all the various
variants is a go to make up the net 3
point 462 million a set out in section
5.4 along with detailed narrative
explanations against each item the items
are presented in that table firstly in
descending order of the fable valances
and then descending order the adverse
variances and in this way readers of the
report an easily ascertained those items
having the larger effects I'd like to
draw members attention to development
control we're planning income is 390
1,000 favorable but we have spent more
on professional ecology landscape advice
as well as in robustly defending
planning Appeals so that net overall for
that area is 82,000 we've also saved
against budget on BIM and revenue
provision which is effectively
depreciation charge
is not so benefited from lower than
budgeted borrowing costs on gateway 14
but the key message I want to convey to
members this is our surplus is primarily
due to additional income as our
day-to-day expenditure is generally in
line with budget there are though
a couple of expenditure items I feel
married to mention members will note the
over in ICT costs and the explanations
given in the report the strategic
planning we show two hundred twenty four
thousand of savings in joint local plan
professional legal and examination costs
but these really just represent delayed
expenditure rather than any real savings
and hence the recommendation is to carry
these forward at the two hundred twenty
four thousand in the joint local plan
earmarked reserve now all the proposed
specific earmarked reserve transfers are
set out in Section five point eight and
request for carry forward sorry
requested carry Florida requests I set
out to section five point nine now the
net effect of all the above is still to
leave one point one sixty five million
to be it was still assigned and I'm
proposing that five hundred thousand we
prudently put aside into a commercial
development risk reserve whilst we are
still in the early stages with the
extensive pipeline of our own local
developments those being gateway
fourteen the various school sites and I
headquarter sites now these developments
by their nature carry a higher risk than
a mature tsypko style income generating
real estate assets after that half a
million they would remain six sixty five
thousand which will transfer to the
growth and efficiency fund the
proficiency fund movements are shown in
a high-level summary in Section 5.10 and
then in Appendix B members will find all
the projects fully itemized turning now
from revenue to capital in the year we
spent thirty four point nine six two
million and incurred capital commitments
of further three point one seven six
million in addition there are seven
our areas in which we wish to make
further capital expenditure but have not
yet made those commitments
these are itemized in section 5:17 and
comprise a total of nine hundred
eighty-three thousand of capital carry
forward requests overall taking all this
into account there's an increase in our
capital program by a further six hundred
seven thousand beyond the revised
capital program a full summary of the
capital program for 1819 is set out in
appendix D members I realized there's a
great deal of detail contained within 25
pages of report 19 slash three for
members to take on board
I'm sure members will join me in
acknowledging all the recent hard work
and diligence of our finance team as
they have closed the financial books for
the year produced a detailed statement
of accounts with both councils as well
as pulling together this report and its
equivalent for Baber
so now prior to answering any members
questions on the report at first like to
move all the recommendations are set out
in section 3 on page 26 with asked for
someone to second that thank you thank
you madam chair and yes I'm more than
happy to second the proposal anybody
have any questions councillor eben
speaks or title mother again thank you
thank you very much chair for if I may
if I've had two questions if I may run
them both at once firstly just with
regard to business rates I just wonder
if you could advise whether there will
be any kind of project or working group
looking at forecasting business rates
for the next year taking into account
that you know there has been a large
one-off payment I just wonder if there's
any work there's going to go on to look
at I'm forecasting that and secondly
with regards to the growth and
efficiency fund I note the transfer of
six hundred sixty five thousand to that
fund but also note that there's a
balance of nine million as shown on
pages 39 and 40 of the report yet at a
yet a balance on Appendix B of only
500,000 to be spent so I just wondered
if you could advise what the plan is for
the remaining amount of the growth and
efficiency fund and whether there are
opportunities to put forward potential
projects for that thank you very much
thank you
when I first got this report obviously
the first thing that hit me was the
extra business rates and so I brought
this up with the finance team and I was
told that as I said in my introduction
it's a key objective of the finance team
to look at ways of improving forecasting
of business rates and I think that
really is a sort of officer tasked thing
to do rather than have a like a member
working part of it because it is so
specific and technical if you like but
yes I can confirm that the saying the
that really is a key object to going
forward I mean most of it is went off
what we're not amounts of income but
it's still frustrating when they come
through
later in the year rather than prancing
they planned ahead just turned to the
growth of efficiency fund as you say yes
I've got 9 million balance on there I
mean thinking back to when this first
started in 2011 it was called a
transformation fund it was very much
most the project I think were very much
financed 50/50 between Baber and Pacific
as part of the working together and
reorganization now we got to the
situation where I don't know the exact
baby favorite moment I think I suspect
it's somewhere more like half a million
compared to our 9 million so going
forward those are opportunities of
working 50/50 or lobster be limited I
think in the past as well we've had two
two councils two groups of members that
bring thought we have to bring forward
ideas as we go forward now with mainly
just a bit cific fund obviously
there's only half the people to do that
so that will slow things down but the
whole idea is to look for growth and
efficiency opportunities and we should
to spend this it was certainly welcome
ideas from all members and I think a
number of I'd this bit of a will of type
of expenses and I think thinking back to
some of the ideas that were brought
forward by the greens a couple of years
ago those were perhaps rather than
before budgeting were more for
transformational growth and efficiency
type spends so yes we'd welcome those
and that there's a lot of money to spend
so let's get on the spender
certainly as as I am blind in my leaders
speech at the last school council I have
got some ideas for spending money I'm
always happy to hear from other people
we've also got ideas for spending money
so I'm happy to have a chat with you and
see what we can come up with councillor
field thank you discussion of spending
money always feels vaguely uncomfortable
in some company but really my question
was just looking looking through this
analysis there's an awful lot of
spenders or income that we didn't expect
and and spend perhaps as is less and
anticipated and awful lot of loan items
where there is substantial overspend
firstly never been in a believer in in
sort of cooking your activity to meet a
budget when you can do more effective
things by being flexible but I just
notice things like costs associated with
the grounds of site maintenance of
course council own car parts was not
previously forecast and there's some
issues in RCT costs things like the
expenditure on software licenses been
identified as ongoing just somewhat
surprised by the level or number of
inaccuracies and was really looking for
the finance portfolio to suggest whether
he's really happy with the accuracy of
the fault our thing always there work to
do there
an interesting question they certainly
would not say I was complacent but I do
feel and this is after a room probably
three years in this particular role and
probably another four or five years of
actually observing the numbers from from
a backbench point of view that the most
of our surprise that have been positive
rather than negative and to me the
amount of detail in the report and the
amount of variances we see highlight
just how how a complex organization and
just how many strands are are that go
through this district council so other
people you know outside and they just
say well the District Council just empty
our bins what else do they do the
reality is that by looking through a
report like this and seeing all the
various headings just demonstrates to me
you know what a complex organization we
have here just how many services we do
provide and but to conclude I do feel
comfortable that we have a good decent
handle on the numbers but I'm not
complacent either I can answer the
question on the ICT costs these were as
a result of implementing Skype for
business the the Skype that we were
using prior to our move here did not
offer us the same benefits as we get now
and unfortunately the costs were not
identified or budgeted for and not only
weren't they included in 1819 but they
also weren't included in 1920 and so
that's why we're doing also doing a more
detailed analysis about telephony costs
and during the process of finalizing a
report which will be coming to SLT in
the near future councillor Brewster
think about chairman and yeah perhaps
one of the finance officers will correct
me if I if I am completely wrong and
what I'm going to say but the car park
charge the charges to the car parks I
believe they may well have been because
of the car park on the oldest site which
was certainly refurbished and after we
purchased our already so there is an
income from that for the car parks as
well I hope I'm right in that there
thank you yes the officers confirmed
councillor whitehead
so just thinking of my fee but possibly
just also add the I never thought to the
question the councilor field raised the
the fact that we have quite a lot of
positive variances in our reports I mean
I think to me that gives it that gives
lie to the concept perhaps again out in
the public that our councils always
spend their budgets and make sure every
penny is spent in March which is why you
see the rows being repaired or whatever
and the fact that we don't just get the
last back to zero there it shows that
you don't have that mentality the fact
that we have some overruns as well we
don't have a mentality to say you've
spent your last penny on budget now stop
spending if there's a valid reason to
spend more then we do spend more and
therefore the overall result of that is
we get positive and negative variances
thank you you know totally agree with
the points that John Whitehead is just
majoring that it's obviously ludicrous
to go spending the the nd or budget on a
million paper clips cuz you want to make
sure that you come in on budget and
that's obviously not something that's
very welcome to see the council doesn't
involve it indulging those of the
practices but it just felt that things
like the Skype costs are pretty
substantial and if you're going to
indulge in an activity like that you
clearly have to
you know estimate what it's gonna cost
before you start declare that get
approval for it and then do it and you
know good we you've been keen on doing
something which is quite modern and
forward-looking but just a bit of a
surprise to see numbers of that song as
appearing in the budget at the last
minute and it's not at the last minute
those were also in the previous report
that came to us but I totally agree
lessons have been learned so any more
questions so I have a proposer
and a seconder for recommendations 3.1
3.2 3.3 and 3.4 on page 26 can have a
show of hands please
all in favor thank you very much moving
on next to item 9 mca 19 slash for the
housing revenue account financial out
turn for 2018-19 and page 51 councillor
whitehead
thank you again madam chairman
and pleased to now introduce the second
out to any port of the day report 19
slash four starting on page 51 which
covers the outer for 1819 of our
ring-fenced housing revenue account this
account covers the council housing stock
which is presently 3285 homes along with
associated garages and land holdings in
the year under review we had budgeted a
linear deficit of 660 mm whilst this
account is still working under the
centrally imposed burden of the one
point sorry the one percent rent
reductions over the four-year period
sixteen seventeen to nineteen twenty
which was centrally imposed by
government but the housing revenue
account must always be reviewed within
the context of the regularly updated
30-year hey char a business plan rather
than just a narrow focus on
one year now the actor we are reporting
shows a deficit of 495 thousand which is
hundred six seven thousand improvement
over budget the table set out in section
five point six shows actual of budget
numbers the various main headings and
then section five point seven sets out
in which greater detail the drivers
behind the various variances in my
introduction today I'd like to bring
certain key items to members attention
person maintenance show the six hundred
seventy two thousand adverse to budget
and of this five hundred twenty five
thousand is attributed attributable to
be MBS which is our very miss of a
building services this is mainly due to
higher than expected external contractor
work carried out during void periods
under the project to reduce the number
of void days now over the last eighteen
months we reduced overall number of void
days from 54 to twenty-five days which
is a fifty-four percent improvement
property services shows 146,000 adverse
variance the bulk of which relate to the
whole house servicing contract with blue
flame sheltered housing shows 111,000
adverse variance which includes
increased utility costs ICT costs
insurance premium and scheme member sort
of scheme manager salary he charges
depreciation shows an adverse parents of
three sixty thousand but in reality this
is balanced by an equivalent improvement
in the funds available in the major
repair reserve now these various adverse
variances have just noted been offset by
a one point four seven eight million
favor variance in respect to the revenue
contribution required to fund capital
outlay 360 thousand this relates the
depreciation contour I just mentioned
and one point one one eight million
comes from using more capital receipts
than anticipated so overall as I said
earlier the net result is four ninety
five thousand in year deficit and this
needs to be taken from our strategic
priorities
reserve the reserve movements are shown
within the table in section 5.6 turning
now from revenue to capital these are
detailed set out in sections five point
nine three to five point fourteen livery
report we spent seven point seven five
seven point seven five five million in
the year and incurred further
contractual forward commitments of two
point one nine nine million in addition
there are carry forward requests
totaling 675 thousand over which 609
thousands for plan maintenance the sixty
six hours for disabled adapt ations
taken all together this takes our
capital commitment to seventy five
thousand over budget but that is less
than 1% of the total HRA capital spend
again prior to answering members
questions on report at first light to
move the recommendations these are set
out in section 3 on page 51
those are at the out term be noted the
four ninety five thousand deficit be
funded from the reserves and the capital
carry forward requests be approved thank
you
well ii uh please
I'm happy to second Dave chair thank you
any questions sorry counselor field a
bit slow expecting other questions when
does it really I was just going to
question the the BMPs
figures it's a pretty substantial
adverse variance but but it obviously
reduces avoid delays and therefore
increases revenue from the housing stock
I wondered if we have any figure for
what the compensating improvement in
revenue was from having places void for
less than half the time they used to be
wanted I don't have that figured myself
just immediately and I don't know where
they were Trisha Gavin Thank You chair
so just to give you some calculations
based on the void performance that
you've seen the average rent for a
council home is 11 pounds and
forty-three pence per day hence a 10-day
reduction in void times would achieve an
additional income of 114 pounds per void
with an average of 200 words per annum
the council would receive an additional
rental income of twenty two thousand
eight hundred and sixty per annum for
every 10-day reduction average for times
of reduced by more than thirty days
since the void project began which is a
total of sixty eight thousand five
hundred and eighty there are obviously
other savings such as council tax
contributions that we don't pay when the
property is occupied and obviously
assuming that some of the properties
occupied are people moving from
bed-and-breakfast or temporary
accommodation then there's obviously
savings from there as well
there's obviously also a social value
associated with that as well but that
was sort of a reasonable return but we
spent 526 K to get about 76,000
with a benefit interesting figure I have
a proposer and seconder so the
recommendations are on page 51 item
three point one three point two and
three point three can I have a show of
hands please input approval
item 10 mca 19 / 5 quarter for
performance outcome reporting on page 63
so cabinet members i would like to
present the quarter for performance
report to you this is the final report
for the 2018-19 financial year whilst
the report provides a summary of our
performance the appeal the appendices
provide greater detail and trends along
with a reflection of some of our key
achievements during the period our
robust performance framework widely
reflects the activities of the council
and will continue to report on measures
associated with our key priorities once
again i'm delighted that there are many
areas in the report where our
performance is exceeding our targets and
over the coming year we will start to
introduce some benchmarking benchmarking
data where possible i would like to
recommend that cabinet members agree
that the performance report and the
performance outcome information tabled
at appendices a2h reflects the council's
performance for january to march and i
would like a seconder for that thank you
I'm happy to second the report Thank You
councillor flapman do we have any
questions
cancer field just a question about the
whole 64
corporate resources says HR o 1 HR o 2
talks about number of days lost due to
sickness and so some good improvements
and things I just wanted to do you have
a measure of the average number of days
lost to sickness per member of staff or
I don't think it's in there and I have
got the figures somewhere but they're
buried in my computer so if it's okay
I'll come back to you on that I'll be
great I'm obviously I mean 10th on
comparing it with the county figures yes
I have got the food because I think they
were dated a couple of months ago but
I'll come back to your nose thank you so
I have a proposal and seconder for MCA
19 / 5 have a show of hands all in
approval
item 11 mca / 19 / 6 regulation of
Investigatory Powers Act 2000 use of
legislation and updated policy on page 1
2 1 so this report is to inform
counselors about issues relevant to the
use of the regulation of Investigatory
Powers Act brackets reaper 2002 provide
a refreshed policy for approval by way
of introduction reaper provides a legal
framework for the council to use covert
methods of surveillance and information
gathering to assist in the detection and
prevention of crime in relation to an
Authority's core functions the
legislation ensures that any
investigator activity conducted by the
council is legal so it's legal
proportionate and necessary it was
introduced to ensure that individuals
rights are protected while also ensuring
that law enforcement and security
agencies including locally thought of
authorities have the powers they need to
do their job effectively
some of the changes I wish to draw your
attention to include the creation of the
investigatory powers Commissioner's
Office IP Co in September 2017 following
the abolishment of the office of
surveillance commissioners OSC the
intelligence services Commissioner's
Office and the interception of
communications Commissioner's Office the
IP Co is now responsible for the
judicial oversight of the use of direct
covert surveillance by public
authorities throughout the United
Kingdom the two legal officers
responsible for acting as the council's
senior responsible officer and Reaper
coordinate coordinator left the
organisation when the shared legal
service was formed though it is very
unlikely for the council's to use Reaper
as confirmed by each Council
nearly statistical return over the past
years there was a recognition that the
existing joint reaper policy should be
refreshed and the key roles reassigned
to appropriate offices a report was
recently presented to the senior
leadership team and the key roles of the
senior responsible officer reaper
coordinating officer and authorizing
officers have now been assigned details
of which can be found in Appendix one of
the attached joint repo policy in terms
of performance monitoring and training
the IP Co have adopted a more flexible
approach to the arrangements for
inspections of local authorities as it
has become apparent in recent years for
a variety of reasons which have included
reduced resources greater access to data
matching and overt rather than covert
law enforcement that most authorities
have granted fewer or no recent
surveillance requests in November 2018
the IP CEO advised that based on the
information provided the councils have
DeMint demonstrated a level of
compliance that removes for the present
the requirement of a physical inspection
the last inspection was carried out in
2015 the IP CEO noted that the draft
joint policy document being presented
today was clear and generally
comprehensive and importantly that an
all training session has been organized
the training day took place on the 13th
of member November 2018 which put the
council's in a position to be able to
apply the act in a lawful and efficient
way if the need arose I therefore
recommend that the refreshed joint
Reaper policy and the changes in respect
of officer roles be approved and the
change in the judicial oversight in the
United Kingdom be noted and I would call
for a seconder thank you
I'm happy to second the recommendations
Thank You counsel do have any question
okay so I have a proposal a seconder for
MCA 19 slash six can I have a show of
hands for approval thank you thank you
very much
item 12 mca 19 / 7 at the end of year
risk position statement and progress
report and revisions to risk management
strategy page 1 5 3 to provide some
clarity to those members new to risk
management i will provide an overview of
the process
the council's significant risk register
is reviewed a quarterly SLT workshops
where each risk is reviewed in terms of
direction of travel scoring and
mitigation still to complete potential
new risks are also discussed each risk
on the register is owned by a member of
SLT and following each workshop session
they will liaise with the respective
member lead to ensure they're up-to-date
on the risk position the register is
reported half yearly to cabinet for
their approval and this report provides
cabinet with the end-of-year
significant risk register and also a
summary of the work of the audit and
risk management services during the last
year this register is at end of March
2019 so some risks may have changed
since this time and another review is
due to be undertaken this month on the
register itself you will see that each
risk tells a story across the page
starting from the initial
inherent scoring through to the current
position and ending with a target score
and outstanding actions to help achieve
this score risks are categorized under
five themes for ease of use the report
that accompanies the register provides
an overview of the register as at 31st
of March 2019 the current risk register
has 27 risks 16 are scored as medium 9
is high and 2 very high
since the previous report to cabinet 1
risk has been removed in quarter 3 which
was we may fail to deliver the financial
projections set out within the B MBS
business plan this risk and associated
actions is now being monitored via the
relevant operational risk register
operational risk registers are in place
for all service areas and are updated at
least akwonton on at least a quarterly
basis assistant directors liaised with
their respective corporate managers
regarding any potential risks that may
need escalating to the significant risk
register more project risk registers are
being created and monitored with the
operational registers located on connect
in addition to the end of in addition to
the end-of-the-year risk register also
attached is the risk management strategy
which has undergone its annual review
minor revisions have been made relating
to the risk matrix providing more
detailed descriptors the risk appetite
section has also been amended under the
operational service delivery risk
section approval from cabinet is being
sought for these amendments finally
finally reporting dates for future risk
reports to cabinet have been slightly
altered to ensure they align with
performance and Finance reports
before I ask Britt any questions can I
please have a seconder for this
counselor flap I'm happy to support the
report three point one on page 153 thank
you
does anybody have any questions cancer
rebate
thank you very much chair I've got kind
of four questions but they're all the
same honor in as it were and that with
regards to several of the risks they're
kind of target for a period over which
the risk is to be reduced seems quite
short so for example community capacity
page 171 that's expected to be achieved
between June and September 2019 gateway
14 page 173 that's expects reduce by
July July which is two months time
council reputation page under 78 that's
expected to be it reaches target in June
to September this year and Universal
Credit page hundred 80 on 4 April 2019
I've just picking out those four I'm
particularly concerned about community
capacity because that's something by
which we really depend upon in this
council in being able to work with our
communities and ensure that we're able
to both meet their needs and work in
partnership with them and I have a
concern that how we were able to meet
those risks within that short time frame
thank you all of those that you
mentioned are spread out across various
portfolio holders
can you just tell me which ones they
were community capacity page what
one-seven-one
just take them one at a time Thank You
counselor travelin I think they tied
that one I agree it's you know whether
they'll you know part of the
relationship as the villages actually
what to do some of this themselves which
is not always possible but I think what
was put in there was that the local plan
would be well on the way by then to
which would help the situation but yeah
I agree we don't know if communities are
going to work with us or not hopefully a
lot of them will especially with that
local plan coming in what was the other
one counseling gateway 14 on page
hundred and seventy-three Brewster
yeah I think there are things moving the
Gateway 14 which which will alleviate
the problems or the the timescale sooner
but June 2019 maybe a little bit early
I'm agree seven if I can assist I'm
assuming we're looking at 2d just for
completeness at the moment you look at
14 my question was that the you know if
we were aiming to to have mitigated that
risk and and met the target by july 2019
that was
we're not that was the clarity oh that's
why I jumped in so that the June the
july 2019 data relates to the immediate
action to the left so the column to the
left so developing the delivery model
will be by july 2019 not reaching the
target as as planned in that respect so
that's what the date relates to relates
to the actions in the column to the left
but presumably that will help reach the
target
council reputation so it's pay 278 it is
risk 5 F 5 F
so exactly the same so as you see on
there and the column further action for
comments those are all the current
activities that are undergoing at the
moment in relation to the council's
reputation and with the red where the
relevant dates aligns to that in terms
of those actions being completed what
you're seeing here and what you see is
risk on us six monthly snapshot basis
what you're not seeing here is the fact
the senior leadership team reviews us on
a regular basis and so when we're
reviewing it will be determining have
those actions being completed and how
have they moved the needle as it were in
terms of the relative nosov that risk
and what further needs to happen in
relation to that risk to help to manage
it the very nature of many of the risks
that you see here is that they will
never disappear entirely it's about the
level of mitigation that we put in place
to mitigate thank you very much and my
last one was five H which is Universal
Credit which I think we've all been
we've all got some concern over
again I've just to assist I think we all
share the same concern on that front and
many of the components of the universal
credit of course are outside of our
control not least that the speed of
rollout of the Universal Credit Scheme
what you see here is our mitigations
again in terms of our management of that
reassuringly at this at the moment we're
not seeing the kind of threats and
impacts that we feared we might through
universal credit but that doesn't read
that as a any level of complacency in
that respect
and we're certainly very mindful of the
impact on our communities that that can
have and so that's one of the key ones
that the the mitigation actions will be
constantly kept under review I just like
to bring in John snow on this one as
well thank you okay thank you madam
chair just to confirm and reiterate some
of the points that are being made around
the table we do actually have a next
workshop in a couple of weeks with
members of a seal and SLT so again we
will rivets at those and certainly take
on board that the comments and part of
that process is to challenge right
through from the risks inherent risks
right through to the residual risk so we
will look at the timings as well to make
sure we're comfortable that they still
are applicable and achievable counselor
women
it's a it's a follow up to five age it
says there that a review a review of
income management strategy and its
outcomes and was to be carried out last
month it is there any feedback from that
and supplementary is at the end of the
day it could well be that this council
will have to pick up some cost as there
are more and more rent arrears or the
converse is that we actually pay to keep
people from being homeless because
that's ultimately rent arrears can lead
to homelessness so have we got
sufficient staff and funding to make
sure that we we don't get into this
situation where people are being made
homeless well I would like to think that
we will be housing people because of the
rent arrears due to universal credit we
can't just throw people out of course
there'll be some some actions put in
place to help these people until it is
sorted out just to ad councils may be
aware of the discretionary housing
payments scheme so every year we see the
amounts of money from government to
assist tenants not just our tenants but
residents more generally where they are
in need in a short term basis what it
can't do is act as rent for a long term
situation because that that's not a
sticky plaster that that doesn't resolve
the issue but for example if you had a
situation where somebody's universal
credit was delayed in terms of them
receiving money so you've got a unique
period of rent arrears that would then
resolve itself over a period of time
something like discretionary housing
payments we have access to that and our
staff have access to that to be able to
help people over that that hub
as councillor Flatman says we're not in
the business of victim people not least
because we're also in the business of
homelessness and so it's entirely
counterproductive from our perspective
to evict people though they won't have
to house or take responsibility for it
in another in another guise our whole
focus and the team sole focus and we've
been able to attract additional
resources in conjunction with West
Suffolk is around homelessness
prevention and that's about sustaining
tenancies were at all costs effectively
so that people are able to stay in their
own homes and that has obviously wider
social benefit values for people's lives
not just that the cost the financial
cost but the stability of being in a in
a home and everything else that comes
with it so yes we do have you know
answer your question against delighted
sorry could I just add as well that
within the publicly available papers
from the shared revenues partnership
there's quite a bit of detail in terms
of the rollout Universal Credit details
of the discretionary housing payments
made by mid Suffolk and you know full
and full narrative behind that
so item 12 have a proposer and a
seconder for the end of your risk
position statement and have a show of
hands in flavor of approval thank you so
item 13 mca 19 / 8 the Thurston
neighborhood Glenn on page 2 0 1
councillor Boone thank you madam
chairman this if memory serves is the
fourth of our neighborhood plans that's
coming up for referendum I just like to
run you briefly through the report cam
in front of you it updates cabinet on
the progress of the Thurston
neighborhood plan and it sets out these
two recommendations that the Parish
Council they requested to make the
necessary modifications in accordance
with the examiner's recommendations and
that subject of satisfactory completion
of those the neighborhood can be
advanced to a local referendum covering
the parish if Thurston office has been
speaking to Thurston parish council
Clarke today and have been advised that
thirst and making good progress on
modifying the neighborhood plan and
should be in a position to send us a
copy for checking later this week
hopefully paragraph 4.2 summarizes the
key consultation dates Paris a 4.32 4.11
provide more detail about the
examination process with key findings
from the final report summarized a
paragraph 4.7
4.14 reminds us that a majority yes vote
that referendum means we must adopt the
plan that is it becomes part of the
development plan framework for the
neighborhood plan area and section six
addresses the financial implications the
twenty thousand pounds
payment is claimable by mid civic once a
referendum date has been set this will
be sufficient to cover all our costs and
will be claimed at the next available
opportunity just one or two key points
from the plan it notes that Thurston is
under continued development pressure it
sets out thirteen objectives and twelve
plan policies themed around spatial
strategy housing and design community
infrastructure movement and environment
it does not allocate sites for housing
development but it does refer to what is
already permitted but it does seek to
focus new development within the
settlement boundary emphasizing the need
for housing to meet the needs of older
people and young first-time buyers now
the policies seek to ensure that
Thurston can continue to grow in
sustainable and controlled manner that
its village character is retained that
its landscape and and environment are
well covered this is in policy ten and
its local green spaces and that new
development promotes sustainable
transport options the railway station
foot crossing remains a major concern
and supporting text within the plan
seeks viable long-term solutions to
passenger safety I would like to propose
the recommendations on page three on
page 201 recommendation 3.1 3.2
and I look for a second please I'm happy
to second the proposal and
recommendations 3.1 3.2 and 3.3 on page
201
there's just three point one and three
point two to have any questions
I have a proposer and high of a seconder
for the Thurston neighborhood Clare
cruises three point one and three point
two on page two zero one can I have a
show of hands insupportable food thank
you item 14 we're going to be moving
into private session so exclusion of the
public which term includes the press to
consider whether pursuant to part one of
schedule 12a of the Local Government Act
1972 the public should be excluded from
the meeting for the business specified
below on the grounds that if the public
were present during this item it is
likely that there would be the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against the item the author
of the report proposed to be considered
in part two of the agenda is satisfied
that the public interest in maintaining
the exemption outweighs the public
interest in disclosing the information I
propose can I have a seconder please
councillor Brewster yes I second the
proposal madam chair can I have a show
of hands in support thank you
you
you